six and a half left wiggins looney steph  draymond and wanna maker  and curry three that's the way to settle  things down  he's gotten told he's starting hot as  soon as he came back  they run nazreet off the line and then  curry comes up with a steal  that was good awareness by wiggins  oh my goodness got it from the ferry  building  drops in another three look at him  talking to the bench  that's what i do yo shooting it from the  hash to take time how far  is too far not a problem for the  greatest distance shooter  ever just left him  [Applause]  a little bit too if you need curry  he will back up and hold him away curry  three  he tried to put vanderbilt in the  blender the move wasn't even that good  but the jumper is so pure  the move doesn't have to be great that's  over length  confidence supreme confidence look at  the command he's like how the move  wasn't that good  but i'm going up to shoot anyway because  my jumper is pure